do you have advice for young people
uh
that just put down their tick tock and
uh are listening to this podcast in high
school and college about how to have a
career how to have a life they can be
part of
so april question but uh
of course it i mean i can give specific
advice for people who want to be writers
and so on but that's a bit niche maybe
um
the writers will be very interesting
sorry to interrupt also how to put your
ideas down on paper and some ideas
develop them
and have the guts to
to go to a large audience
especially when the ideas are sort of
controversial or dangerous or difficult
well the main thing to do is to breed
when i was a school boy i'd forever have
a book in my pocket
um
side pocket in my jacket or inside
pocket
and would read and
that wasn't
just because i was swatish in some way
but because i discovered
probably at some point in my early teens
i discovered something i wrote about
this one
i discovered that books
were dangerous
which was a thrilling discovery yeah
um
i discovered that they could contain
anything
and also people didn't know what you
were reading
i remember i get far too young in age i
read the doors of perception of aldous
huxley
um
and um
i i
didn't make head or tail of it probably
but i knew that it was about something
really interesting and dangerous
and i thought constantly when i read
poetry or read history and
i was just constantly um
thrilled and wanted to know more
and
and well if you want to become a writer
you you have to be a reader
um
you have to read the best stuff
um and and you know obviously people
disagree or agree on what that is and
you'll find the people that really
impress you
but i know i just came across certain
writers who just
knocked me off my feet
um
and
when you find those people like read
everything and cling on to them and find
other people like that find other
writers like that or people who are
connected
by history or
scholarship or circles or whatever
for you was it fiction or non-fiction is
there particular books that you just
remember
or just give you pause well i remember
that the first book that absolutely
threw me was the lord of the flies
of william golding which used to be a
signed text and everyone's a bit snotty
about because it's so popular
um but i was thrown because i think it
was the first adult book i read
in that i had been used to the world of
children's literature of
everything ends up fine in the end the
lost all get found
you know and this was the first book i
read where that's not the case
the world turns out differently and and
i remember for days afterwards i was
just in a state of shock
i
couldn't believe
what i'd just discovered
and partly because i sort of intuited it
must be true
and of course that's not to say that the
lord's like there's lots of scholarship
on
what children do in the situation of
being on the island when they do
congregate and anyhow
but yes that was a sort of introduction
to the adult world and it was shocking
and thrilling and um and i wanted more
of it
um it was dangerous and it was dangerous
and then of course when i became
interested in sex let alone when i
realized i was gay i realized books were
a very very good way to learn about what
i was
and that was even more dangerous in a
way and i thought i mean nobody knows
what i know and
you discovered sex that was an invention
in books what do you mean
what i mean
no no no no what i mean is that one of
the things that gay people have when
they're growing up is that
you have this terribly big secret and
you don't think the world will ever know
you hope the world will never know
and
um
it's been called by one psychologist the
little boy with a big secret and
so if you discover that other people
have the same secret there's a sort of
thank god for that
um but i mean that's just a version of
what everybody gets in reading in a way
which is the thrill of discovery that um
somebody else thought something you
thought only you'd thought i mean
one of the greatest one the greatest
thrills in all of literature is when a
voice comes from across the centuries
and seems to leave a handprint you know
it makes you feel a little bit less
alone because somebody else feels yeah
sees the world the same way is the same
way that's what cs lewis says it says
said to have said we read to know we're
not alone
um but we don't only read no not alone
we read to become other people
um
i mean i think i saw in books the
version of the life i wanted to live and
then i decided to live it
and for i'm fortunate enough to have
done so
um i wanted to live in the world of
ideas and um books and debate and
i wanted to live in the debates of my
time you know
and i remember i remember when um
like a lot of people i read auden when i
was young and uh
you know certain lines obviously stuck
with me but i'm i that poem of his which
everybody you know
knows and which he hated
uh september the first 1939
i remember certain lines in that it just
say whacked me
um what's that one sitting on a dive and
40 seconds
degrading it alone
at the end of a low dishonest decade of
course there's a problem with that line
which is you kind of want to be living
at the end of a low dishonest decade as
well it sounds sort of cool in a way you
know you're the only person who sees it
but um so yeah anyhow there's a
diversion but the point is if you want
to be a writer you've got to be a reader
apart from anything else you discover
the the lilt of language and the
the things you can do and i i've read
people who and i still do who i think my
god i didn't how did you do that in fact
books books for me now and articles and
other things fall into two categories
one is i know how you did that
and the other is i don't know how you
did that
and
the and the best feeling as a writer is
when you do the second one and i've and
it happens occasionally in my writing
life will you almost like return to
something you've written or like right
after you no the moment you write it you
wonder how did i do that yes
that's that's the most i've never said
that before that's the happiest thing in
writing yeah
very occasionally it sounds but i mean
i've occasionally
finished something
funny enough it happened some years ago
in a long piece i wrote about the artist
basquiat
um
i i finished the piece and i gasped
because i didn't know
because because that's also a thing with
writing is you
you you it's not sometimes people say
you need to write in order to know what
you think that's not quite true
sometimes you that's a very bad piece of
advice for some writers who don't know
what they think and it's not going to
become clearer if they just start typing
very hard yeah sometimes it is true that
you there's a thought that's just
waiting there and a clarity that comes
across and suddenly the sentence emerges
in your brain and by the time you typed
it you you just go
yes
that's the greatest feeling of the
writing almost like it came from
somewhere else that's that's what um uh
um buckingham
says about you know what's the moment is
tom stoppard's favorite quote about you
know peculiarly saying what happened to
the moment where the right to other
writer's pen when he pauses where does
he go in that moment
um
yeah
that's so interesting
that's that's so because i think the
answer to that question will help us
explain consciousness and all those
other weird things about the human mind
yes so that was advice for writers i
didn't really give any advice for people
in general but um is that oh you want to
give health advice no to your channel a
churchill and no i don't give health
advice clearly
because you implied that churchill was
one of your early guides in that aspect
you